you know everybody knows a typical
Michael Chandler fine I'm gonna put my
foot on the gas get in his face put him
on his back foot early and yeah try to
knock him out my Mystic Mike prediction
I knock him out in the second round I
beat him up pretty bad wear him down in
the first make him second guess himself
and then bam hit him with a hard one in
the second he goes down and we jump on
the cage maybe a backflip we'll see
oh no Brandon
my man Mr Chandler you've gone Hollywood
dog
I'm trying dude you know me just trying
to go Hollywood man Mr big time you went
you won the freaking Conor McGregor
sweepstakes and I say wanted I mean
you've earned it man and last time we
spoke we were hoping for Conor McGregor
fight man and here we are you're
freaking you know you're going against
the dude on The Ultimate Fighter series
which is dear to my heart that's how I
got my career how you doing buddy how
you doing with everything you're busy
man we were talking yesterday you're
like I'm gonna Zoom I'm headed to this
meeting and then right now you're like
we got to get this going like you're a
busy dude I'll try man well I don't like
people waiting on me number one so we
had some webcam issues going on
um but yeah man where I was life is good
uh excited that this show comes out here
in a couple weeks I've been kind of you
know obviously we got done filming it in
March so here we are May so it's been
you know a long process kind of waiting
for it and I know it's going to be an
awesome show people are going to love it
on ESPN like you said you know last time
we spoke you said I was the UFC cash cow
man
and I was like well you know we'll see
uh we'll see what happens and then uh
turns out here we are Ultimate Fighter
ESPN which was an awesome show
experience by the way and then uh
fighting Conor later this year whenever
we figure out a date oh we'll get to
that but did you have a you had a good
time shooting Ultimate Fighter because I
I was a I was a coach on there for the
six weeks when I think it was season 14
with Shane Carwin Roy Nelson
so it's such a different experience as a
coach and as a fighter did you ever
because to be honest some fighters who
do end up being coaches don't enjoy the
experience because you're you're in
Vegas it is a lot of work you know it's
like if you actually care it's a lot of
work and I know you're a guy that when
you do something you're all in so I'm
sure it was a lot of work for you yeah I
mean I think I think that's what I
vastly underestimated how hard it was
going to be but you can make anything as
hard or as easy as you want I could have
shown up you know gave half a
half-hearted effort
um but as soon as I met my guys and I
shook their hands look him in the eye
and said hey man I'm proud to be your
coach immediately fell in love with
every single one of their stories why
they're there the ups and downs that
they've had in their career the things
that they've struggled with
um and it made me want to pour into them
that much more so every single morning
woke up I had a few minutes to kind of
do my morning routine focus on myself
and then it was hit the ground running
non-stop thinking about them how do I
get each of these eight fighters in the
best possible situation not all of them
are gonna be able to win The Ultimate
Fighter because you know there's only
one per weight class
um but we can at least give them the
best opportunity to either become that
guy who gets the contract or become that
guy who shows up on ESPN in front of
millions of people and pulls on the
heartstrings or wins people over even if
he didn't win his fight he's still might
get that UFC contract and I I I took
that to heart I took I took that that
pressure and that ownership of their
careers
um very seriously so I think I made it a
little bit harder on myself than a lot
of coaches would but
it's how I like to do things like yeah
it was a very good experience it's a
very good yeah I expect nothing less you
know I'm sure Connor was a great coach
but when I when I looked at him like oh
a lot of guys are going to be on
Chandler's team a lot of guys because I
know you're gonna put it in but also
going back to you know there's guys that
win The Ultimate Fighter and obviously
they're guaranteed a contract but for
the guys and it's changed over time
because probably uh price in season I
don't know 11 12 is it just it changed
you know it's just you know obviously
they weren't on Spike anymore and it was
it got a little diluted stuff like that
and now I think the seasons especially
since you encounter on this and it's
ESPN these guys are going to get that
fan base when before if I was managing
Fighters I'd say do Dana White Contender
series that's a much better way to get
into the UFC but now that it's a
Chandler Conor McGregor it's on ESPN
everybody's gonna be able to see it now
those guys you have six weeks and that's
how I viewed it when I was in the house
I have six weeks to make name for myself
and and to get a fan base whether I win
it or not the plans to win it but if you
don't you're still going to have that
opportunity so even if you don't win the
show if you're a semi-finalist like I
was or if you have a good showing and
people Vibe with you the UFC's still
going to give you that shot you know so
those kids need to realize like this is
their moment literally six weeks
yep and well that's and that's what I
was telling them too and and because
ultimately you know everyone's vying for
that that spot to be the winner of the
show obviously but you can never
underestimate or undervalue just being
who you are create a fan base create a
following even if you're the worst guy
on the team so to speak you could still
win the hearts and minds and be the guy
who gets the UFC contract because you
have such a great following because you
know the UFC is really good at knowing
where the analytics are where the
impressions are who people are talking
about who's using the hashtag they
understand they understand who who is
trending well that's more important
sometimes than the X's and O's of
winning fights and it probably is
actually more important so I told those
guys that was able to talk to them about
the business and The Branding side of
being a mixed martial artist and um man
it was a lot of fun I love team Chandler
team Chandler loved me man we had a
really really good time a really good
camaraderie on our team and even the
guys on the other team man I still was
vibing with a lot of those dudes too
because ultimately yeah they're on
Connor's team but they're still like hey
man that's Michael Chandler he's been
there done that been watching him for
years so it was cool to even cross the
line or across over Enemy Lines a little
bit and see the guys and talk to them go
to the house hang out with them because
ultimately I wanted the best for
everybody on the show I wanted the best
for team Chandler mainly because we
wanted to win for sure but ultimately
everybody there was cool and I think
there's gonna be a lot of guys are gonna
become Stars uh after the show if they
can continue what they've been doing
yeah and what's the what's the theme
this year like as far as like you know
when when it was my season it was
heavyweights uh before that they've
they've brought back older dudes who
didn't have a shot in the UFC and this
is you know well they had a shot didn't
go well and they bring them back is I've
heard a little bit of the Rumblings I'm
not paying too close to close attention
to it is this the same thing guys who
have fought before and they're bringing
them back
so that's yeah that's that's been out
there obviously and they also released
the uh they released the names of the
guys you know and I think they did that
toward the end of the show they actually
put it on one of the fights so
um yeah you know so which would make
sense you know kind of get people hyped
up and whatnot but yeah I think the idea
is the prospects versus the the uh the
veterans you know so it's uh yeah so
it's cool you know you would think hey
the prospects they're they're young and
they're salty and they they haven't
gotten the shop and then you think hey
the veterans have gotten the shot uh but
this is their opportunity to get that
shot back get their second chance you
know very few times in life do you get a
a great opportunity at a second chance
and this is a great opportunity for a
second chance so
um yeah man it's uh it's cool it was a
fun season and uh it was eventful you
know obviously you've been seeing the
promos out there you know got a little
got a little handsy with Connor a little
yeah why do you push your face like that
I don't know it was it was an
interesting move I kind of liked it you
know it was pretty cool you know I was
like ah bunch of the face all right I
like it yeah
yeah well and also also too it's in the
heat of competition I mean say what you
want about Connor Connor you know he's
he's a competitor he wants to win he
wants to win every single fight he wants
to win the show he wants to beat me
later this year
um so of course the ups and downs of the
the The Ultimate Fighter experience you
know you got the fights going on he's
you know he's in Vegas for four weeks
five weeks I'm in Vegas we're away from
where we where we is home if you will
you're living on the road there's all
and you've got a camera in your face all
the time wearing a microphone the whole
time it's it's a different experience as
you know
um but yeah I mean it was a lot of fun
yeah did you were you surprised by
Connor uh in a positive negative way how
how he was with the kids I was off
camera I was on camera because there's
one thing to be around Connor he has
this energy there's a reason why he's
such an outlier amongst all of us and
when you see it like oh I I get it I get
it I can't do that what I do I do well
but what he does it's just he just has
this Aura but he has this energy we're
in the same room did you change your
perspective being you know shooting a
show with him being around him this long
on camera off camera do you see a
different guy or
um Conor's definitely good at turning it
on when the cameras come on you know he
he becomes the notorious Conor McGregor
and then outside of the cameras he's
he's actually very similar in both
senses to be honest with you but but
it's it's definitely like hey when that
when it's time to go it's it's show time
and you know we're not worried about
feelings we're not worried about what we
say we're not worried about what happens
we just uh kind of see what happens you
know
um but ultimately too you know I had to
spend a lot of time around Connor I
thought the same thought of the same
card as him my debut in the UFC so I
shared a press conference with him he
was he was the nice Connor for that that
fight that second fight with Poirier
um so he was definitely a little bit
different than he was on the shower now
but also you know Connor is a a a larger
than life figure to a lot of people we
see a ton of him in the media on online
all over the place
um but to spend that much time around
him the human being being in the same
room with him you know just like you
have might have seen guys in the media
and watched what they've done but then
you get in the same room with them and
it humanizes them yeah you know it it
it's a you know two arms and two legs
and it's a human being exactly you know
so that was that was interesting so it
actually I think it was a good thing I
was gonna say that helps you right a
little bit it helps you yeah yeah
instead of instead of you know because
maybe the first time we see each other
is at a press conference now you're
you're fighting against him on a press
conference and he's still that Mystique
guy compared to spending your normal
everyday life with them where it's like
hey I just got back from lunch he's
going to lunch or we he's walking in the
training room I'm leaving the training
room and you just see him living his
normal life not always on if you will or
not the the figure that he is so it was
cool to you know be there humanizes him
a little bit he was able to you know
we've sized each other up a little bit
you know he's we now we see the size of
each other the way we move and you know
our commitment to our our teams and
whatnot so it was uh it was good and I'm
excited to decided to compete against
him and were you were you surprised at
his at his coaching obviously Connor has
a high fight IQ and obviously you do too
so you know I knew you'd be a great
coach I I'm with Connor I don't know
that's why I want to see what how he
interacts with the kids those kids you
know again I was there you rely so much
on the coach you really do especially
Rashad was my coach he's been through
that so what he said carried so much
weight I'm sure those kids are looking
at you and Connor same thing man you
guys have so much power and it's a great
responsibility towards these kids
yeah for sure I mean obviously me and
Conor are different in a lot of ways I
think uh you know he's he's he has built
a ridiculous brand uh my brand is is not
where his is but it's continued to grow
um just through who I am and how I
conduct myself inside mixed martial arts
so I knew I think my guys knew whether
they were on my team or Conor's team
there was there was a different approach
by each coach but I do think you know
watching him in the practices or seeing
some clips that have been leaked or
whatnot I mean he was he was there he
was he's he's talking he he he talks a
lot I mean you even see him at bare
knuckle you know coaching guys you saw
him at the Ryan Garcia fights coaching
guys after the fight hey right you know
talking to Ryan Garcia hey you could
have done this you know kind of the and
I don't know if he's just playing up the
Conor's a coach right now you know while
the ultimate Fighter's about to go or
you know but I think he is he looks at
the game and he's not afraid to give his
opinion where I'm more of a you know in
normal life I would never walk up to a
guy who just lost a fight and be like
hey man you probably should have done
this maybe I should but with the with
yeah with my guys when I'm when we're
training and it's like hey man you got
to be better at this you've got to get
get off the wall you got to get up you
got to grab the wrist here you gotta and
they can feel it even if I might have
rubbed them the wrong way here and there
they knew it came from a
a good place because we have to put them
in the best situation possible to win on
Fight Night so go going through this
whole experience if you're asked to do
it again would you would you have said
yes it's a lie yeah when I think when I
got done with it I came back and I just
felt adrenaline dump hungover for like a
week or two you know it was it was tough
being on that that much every single day
because we actually filmed it in four
weeks we filmed it all in four weeks
which means two weeks less which means
yeah so it's less than usual because we
had a hard stop we had to get done with
it but also because it was four weeks we
had to cram everything in so there was
there was no off days there was like one
or two actual off days in a 30-day
period so
um I think if I was asked to do it again
if you ask me by the time it gets done
and it airs and we see the momentum
behind it the viewership the response I
mean it's gonna be really cool
um if you would ask me right away I'd be
like I don't think I ever want to do
that again but now I'm like now I'm like
I was four weeks and it was it was fun
it's going to be a huge show
um I would definitely do it again so it
was a lot of fun painful painfully hard
yeah yeah there's a reason right if it
was easy everybody would do it
um how do you think knowing what the
kids go through and stuff like that and
I'll switch to it in four weeks is
absolutely insane six weeks is insane
for the fighters looking at the fighters
you think if you would have went that
path you would have done well in The
Ultimate Fighter house because it's
different right you're dealing with
different it's I always tell people that
are going into it when they ask me for
advice I go it's you're not in the UFC
that lifestyle is not a UFC lifestyle
it's a very intense different type of
fighting style and you got to worry
about injuries if you're cutting weight
that's a different animal and you're
dealing with all these personalities you
can't really Escape it like that's
that's the UFC kind of on steroids but
also the fights there's nobody really in
the room so it's not it don't get me
wrong it's fighting but it's not UFC
fighting yeah yeah for sure I mean
there's what those guys had to go
through was a lot harder than what I had
to go through I think you know I mean
you know the ultimate fighter house it's
obviously it's changed since the house
that you were in and I think they
bounced around a couple different times
I mean you're talking 16 guys one house
couple bathrooms but then only a couple
bedrooms too so you could be in a uh in
a bunk bed with you know there's gonna
be six guys in one room you know so it's
like like you say you can't escape it
you can't escape it you know you can
kind of see it wearing on the guys you
know some days are just like dude this
is tough and then but then the fights
get closer or the weight cut gets closer
and then they start to kind of rise to
the occasion so it's it's just as much a
mental battle as it is the physical
battle because truthfully too I was
getting those questions too kind of
before when it got announced hey how are
you going to coach the guys and truth be
told and say hey man these these guys
got their certain attributes and there's
really not a lot you can change in a
couple weeks period point you know so
physically hopefully they came in in
shape and hopefully they got a good set
of skills and we're going to fine-tune a
couple of them we're gonna and we're
gonna fix a little deficiencies but
mainly I want these guys right here yes
to believe that they can go out there
and believe that this is their
opportunity you know believe that that
they could be the the winner of this
thing if someone's got to be the winner
why shouldn't it be you so that was my
main goal
um but yeah I mean the the fact that you
can't escape it a couple times I went to
the house and visited then I started
realizing the the atmosphere they were
living in I'm like man this is this is
tough for sure for four years
if you watch those people like volunteer
to go into prison it's kind of like 60
days in yeah well and and what some
people are a lot of people don't know
too is they probably think they got
access to phones radios TVs there's
nothing no you know books yeah oh yeah
yeah no books so basically no form of
entertainment aside from they were
playing you know I might play like
Checkers or cards or whatever they had
like little games like that no we can't
even do that we could there's no
Checkers we we drew uh like cards to
play like pokers they got rid of those
Justin Wren brought a Bible they took
his Bible away I was like oh my gosh
this is insane dude and also that wasn't
thinking about that was I shot that in
2000 uh shoot man 2009 like early 2009
cell phones weren't like they they were
around but it wasn't like it is now so
think about those younger kids who are
addicted to Tick-Tock and Instagram and
all that and then they gotta go cold
turkey for four weeks dude yeah so you
think about that and then you also think
about you know it's 24 hours in a day
and they're only showing an hour per
episode so the you are the the viewers
on uh ESPN this summer are only going to
see 12 hours of footage and only parts
of that is going to be actually in the
house so the 24 hours in a day that
you're stuck in this house can't leave
they they say they all signed an
agreement like hey if I go over this
like they they had a basketball court
and if the ball bounced out they had to
like go ask for permission because if
they jump that fence to go you know
they're like hey you're out we'll kick
you out because you know because you got
to control these guys obviously
liability you're stuck there like you
said it's kind of like prison it's got
you know so just to obviously we're not
giving away anything that's not already
out there yourself exactly that's what
it is but but I think people don't quite
realize what it's like to be stuck in a
it was almost a pro a a privilege and a
present to be able to leave the house to
go to training you know you know wait
yeah it's only going to switch things up
the only time you leave those four walls
right so it's uh it was uh it for me it
would be very very tough you know you're
just sitting there they're basically
forcing you to talk to these people and
maybe you like them maybe you don't
maybe you and me are fighting each other
two days from now and now where your
room is right next to mine correct you
know yeah yeah man my buddies you see
him going through his morning routine
you're like oh man you see him focusing
you know that morning and you have that
fight that night it was so I just if if
you have to describe in one word intense
it was so intense it was really it's
always on you're always on there's
always an escape it you can't escape it
there's always a camera you know those
necklaces I don't know if it's still
that the necklaces are the kids mics
then also what I found
sad but also gave me confidence is when
in when you live in the house and
there's 16 guys when the guys would lose
and they still have to stay in the house
because there's still got to be training
parts so you'd see their dreams just get
shattered especially the guys that lost
in the first round and okay they came in
just full of Hope and this is my moment
and then you just just see their dream
get snatched and you got to be around
they're stuck but you got to be around
that and you still got to stay focused
for your fight you've seen this guy
who's just distraught you know writing
Love Letters to his girl when I get back
I'm done with this stupid fight game
you're like yeah and you're still trying
to do your thing man it's an insane
experiment yeah it is an experiment too
it's a perfect way to put it because
you're like this is this is an
experiment in The Human Condition and
even as a coach too obviously you know
you've got to deal with that guys you
know guys winning or losing and you got
your guys in or you got your guys out
and then you're then it's like okay how
do you how do you handle these guys you
know they're not part of the competition
anymore but they're still part of your
life they're still part of of the team
you still want to say hey man maybe your
dreams got shattered I get it here this
is horror is a tough situation but hey
man you know come show up for your team
I'm here for you but you know I still
got to focus on these guys who are
trying to win this competition if you
will so it's I mean it's it's a crazy
experiment was a perfect way to put it
and the other thing you got to realize
too with those guys and we didn't know
that at the time because you know it was
only season 10 but those especially I
was younger but you got to remember like
you said those those episodes only an
hour long you know so those kids who are
there in your case four weeks behind six
weeks they're gonna edit certain things
so you got to be aware like they can
paint a narrative and I I don't agree
like I know some people from the past
ultimate fires go they edited and made
me look like an [__] I'm like no dude
you're an [__] like this show opened
your you're just an [__] like maybe
you're not an [__] all throughout the
day but when you're in that setting in
training or whatever you act like an
[__] man he's like no they edit that
way I'm like no you said that stop
enough dude so I never co-signed where
they're like oh it's the editing and
make me look bad I'm like no dude that
you did that stuff they're not telling
you the right things you know and I came
off as arrogant because you know it's a
fight and you want to show confidence
and you're you believe in your training
so you know I talk [__] about some
Fighters or say certain things and if
people only see that like oh this kid's
arrogant it's like no that's a version
of me getting ready for competition I
was very confident in my skills but
that's not me that's me getting ready
for a fight that's all it is yeah you
yeah you know you inside of a training
camp or as you get toward those last
couple weeks of training camp fight week
fight night you're not Brandon I'm not
Michael I'm not like I'm not the guy
that my my wife's married I'm not my my
son's dad this this guy right and then
all of a sudden we get done with the
Fight Win Lose or Draw we got to go back
and then we can be normal again but
that's what these guys lived for you
know four weeks if you will and then
also you can kind of see it too you know
obviously they draw for the fights you
know who who's gonna fight first week
who's gonna fight second week all that
different kind of stuff you could see
the the shift in in guy's mentalities
there was a little bit of happy-go-lucky
stuff when they knew they didn't have a
fight for what maybe maybe be a week or
two or whatever whatever it might be you
know it's like a relief you're like okay
I can kind of chill for a second and
then all of a sudden it flips the other
guys who were fighting go back to okay I
can let the guard down a little bit act
like a normal person but then the other
guys go straight into psycho mode you
know so it's it was fun man it was and
it was for me I just felt like every
single day I was I was just reacting
because you never know even though most
of the days are pretty similar hey we're
training it this time we're training at
that time here's the guys here's what
we're doing these guys are fighting
weight Cuts but here's a kind of plan it
all out every single day was still a
crap shoot in a lot of different ways
you're miked up on camera in real time
at all times constantly thinking about
what you're saying what you're doing
where you're at what's happening so it
was an experience man but it was uh I
would definitely say it was a positive
one it was a good one you know come what
may like you said I I'm already seeing
you know a little bit of a tweaking of
of editing and whatnot when you know
when Connor say you'll do what you're
told I'm like okay so I was just sitting
there like that yeah I didn't say
anything yeah yeah yeah oh my God you
know they even know what kind of like
now we know they're already starting to
paint it you can't control that crush me
yeah
the trash talk game so I'm okay with it
you know so we'll it's uh all of it is
is fun and it's about to be a fun 12
weeks you gotta glow about you obviously
we don't want to reveal anything but I
can tell you [__] did well your team
did well because you're a good coach
I've seen you coach you're a good coach
and what the hell you're doing this can
be good man I could tell you did well
it's gonna be good I love team Chandler
man they're they're good man and we're
going to keep reliving The Experience
too like we're you know we're in my
studio right now
um we're gonna do a tough reaction show
every single week
um you know just kind of on your network
or ESPN doing that well I am doing one
with ESPN so I'm actually gonna go live
with Dean Thomas after everything
um for only it's not gonna be very long
maybe a 10 minute little clip deal
um but I'm gonna be doing my own show
right here too where we can maybe it's
maybe Wednesday morning or
um Tuesday night whatever we decide but
it's going to be kind of in real time
well guys just got done with it
can't believe this happened here's
here's how it actually went down yeah I
believe I can't believe they showed that
or hey now you guys know what I'm
talking about now you know why it was
that kind of first-hand experience of
this was tough so I might actually have
to have you on there especially because
you're uh you have the experience just
who you are now yeah let me know brother
and I'll be reaching out to you yeah
because I'm gonna be I haven't paid
attention ultimate fighting a hot second
this got me excited you know I can't
wait here's what's crazy dude here's
what's crazy when you came out I was
like dude you're the you're the the show
Pony for the UFC like you can get some
big looking back on things
my god did it work out when you left
Bellator yeah right dude like you're the
you're the you're the guy you're the
example it's like a lot of guys have you
know left UFC went to Bellator vice
versa Bella toward the UFC or go on to
one Championship or we're at pfl but my
God if I'm a agent manager like look at
Chandler he did it yeah look dude what a
freaking story dude yeah it's worked out
really well man and it was a tough
decision I'm talking to you about it you
know on on network or on on camera off
camera as friends you know it's these
are tough decisions that you're making
because you you know I had a really
great thing going and there was a huge
risk that I was going to take but if the
huge risk has now become a huge reward
and here we are a couple days away a
week and a half away from being on ESPN
for 12 weeks straight and then fighting
Conor and it's uh it's worked out well
man so just you bet on yourself you bet
on yourself and you know in correlation
on that it's also like I'm sure you're
aware of the Francis ingano news you
know uh sign with the pfl have you seen
the terms on that deal and stuff like
that
some of it um if you yeah you could you
could brush me up and I saw some of it I
still have a hard time believing that he
was going to make as much money as he
would in the UFC as the UFC champion
with pay-per-view stuff you know but
sometimes it's more about it's more for
some people a very rare sector of people
it's less about the money and more about
the impact and I think that's kind of
where francis's heart is I mean so I
think uh yeah I wish him well I I saw
him in Vegas actually I ran him to it at
a steakhouse hey man what's happening
what are you doing you know what's
what's next
um and uh you know it uh he was we were
talking about boxing we were talking
about whatever and it uh you know worked
out well for him so yeah I think it
worked out well the the pressure I don't
think is on Francis you know he he
signed the deal it's the most lucrative
deal we've seen a hot second the
pressure's on pfl the the the things
that they need to pull off in order to
get their investment back after giving
France all that stuff so Francis did
great for him now the pressure's on pfl
to see if they can pull it off they
don't have the roster to fulfill to sell
pay-per-views to give them a portion of
the gate so hats off to Francis and
Markel they did it not the NFL's like
okay we better figure this out so the
pressure's on one man well yeah and
they're and they're basically diving
into a brand new market for them they
have never sold a pay-per-view you know
it's you saw Bellator do it they didn't
do very good you know they've never
Tyler didn't know what they did with
Kyla Harrison I think it did like oh 5
000 pay-per-views but I'm not trying to
be funny it did maybe 50. you might have
to look at that it did not do well but
it pay-per-view model's a little it's a
different animal so again the pressure's
on them but again Francis banking
himself this thing is still success I
think if he can get the big boxing fight
and Anthony and Joshua announced today
um he had a statement going no I'm not
gonna do that you know that circus act
and fight Francis I'm like oh no so well
I I hope it works out for him it's tough
yeah because now he's put himself in a
position where he's kind of a
you know I guess you guys you could say
circus you could say he's different you
know just because he went out but but
still he was the UFC champion you know
baddest man on the planet if you will or
whatever so it um it's unfortunate it
could blow up in his face but that's why
you know sometimes you take big risks
and it works out well sometimes you
don't sometimes it's more intrinsic than
it is extrinsic look at you like I said
I said look at you you know yeah now you
went through a big machine and pfl is
not the same machine so it's it's still
different but at least he bet on himself
you know yeah one from where he came
from and true rags to read stories he's
in a good spot so my King's still Jon
Jones at heavyweight but whatever
whatever that's fine
um yeah now I guess the biggest question
is my only concern with the I think this
season ultimate fires me huge it's gonna
be massive is it gonna beat season 10 of
course not but it's gonna do well right
so my only caveat with that is
I would feel so much better about it if
I knew when you and Connor were gonna
fight that would make me feel so much
better do we have any insight on no no
Insight really but I do think that's the
general sentiment by a lot of people
it's almost like we're watching this
show should we be excited about alter
cases between Chandler and McGregor or
is he are they not going to fight it
definitely makes a show better if we
know when the fights happen so you know
Conor came out the other day and said
there's gonna be a fight announcement
soon or you know a date soon so I think
I won't really get you know nervous or
anything about it till June 1 you know
um that's when I kind of put my time
limit on it if you will but for now you
know we're gonna enjoy the ride Connor
loves the sport of mixed martial arts he
loves being the guy he loves being in
the bright lights in the in those
stadiums and whatnot so I think he's uh
he's coming back he can't do all oh you
guys are fighting 100 yeah well it's
like you don't know when yeah there's no
doubt in my mind that you and Conor are
gonna fight guarantee it if I had to bet
on I'm a betting man but I bet November
Matt Square Garden that's why I bet Nova
I've kind of been leaning that way I
haven't been told that at all no me
neither this is me completely pissing in
the wind here yeah it's a big uh it
could be a big show obviously November
is always huge uh for them usually
Madison Square Garden 38th anniversary
of the UFC so I mean that kind of makes
sense you always kind of start putting
the pieces together of what the big
shows big fights big venues would be and
that one kind of makes sense but you
know I'm not here to figure that out no
you just keep doing your things keep
crushing it when you look at uh Conor
the other thing that's kind of tough I'm
I'm trying to put myself in your shoes
when you and Connor do fight it's like
what version of Conor is Chandler gonna
fight because it's kind of up in the air
you know if you look at the Aldo tape
when he's at 45 well that doesn't make
much sense you look when he fought Eddie
Alvarez he's different even when he was
at 55. look at the Nate Diaz fights I
guess the khabib I guess and then do we
do we know what weight class you're fine
at is that 70 I think Dana said
I think it's a 170. if I had a guess
yeah it's not 155 and it's not 185 like
we were joking I don't think I would
love to fight a 185 but uh
I think it's going to be once yeah I
think it's gonna be 170 but uh yeah I
mean I I agree with you and I think
Conor's been carrying around this new
weight that he's been building for the
last two years he's been carrying around
for about the last you know year or so
I've been carrying this body mass around
for the last 15 years you woke up like
it'll be interesting to see yeah so
it'll be it'll be interesting to see how
he performs or what kind of fight style
he's going to be how well he moves um
are we gonna see the Aldo type you know
karate stance fight and you know like
like he was at 45 we're going to see
more of a Precision striking killer like
he was against Alvarez like you said or
is he going to be a little bit slower
less movement less whatever because now
he's a little bit heavier put on some
muscle mass so we'll see I also think
this is the first time in Conor's career
he's fighting guy who has more knockout
power than him I think it's the very
first fight he's ever had where he's
finding a guy who actually hits harder
than he does
I believe I believe that you know for me
but I also yeah I also think he knows
that yeah um which excites me you know
but you know everybody knows a typical
Michael Chandler if I mean I'm gonna put
my foot on the gas get in his face put
him on his back foot early and yeah try
to knock him out my Mystic Mike
prediction I knock him out in the second
round I beat him up pretty bad wear him
down in the first make him second guess
himself and then bam hit him with a hard
one in the second he goes down and we
jump on the cage maybe a backflip we'll
see yeah maybe back flip I assume a
backflip oh I assume we're back did you
did you see they announced that July
card is so freaking stacked but then
ounce uh Justin Gayton uh Dustin poye
too man for the BMF belt dude good for
those guys man right the BMF belt
they're definitely two bmfs for sure
um tough fight to call uh oh it's a
toss-up thing it's a toss-up so so
whoever lands that night is going to be
the one who ends up winning but they're
both part of a champion great cardio
great striking both hit really hard
um so that'll be a fun one I might have
to go to that one actually so yeah be at
that one yeah um for for you too it's
like with this Conor fight you're at 155
but you're gonna fight Connor at 70.
look you beat Connor you're probably the
you know biggest aim at 55. so you go
right back to 50 does it do you think a
win over Conor gives you the title shot
55 I would assume so
I I Never Say Never and I'm never going
to say that I deserve that but I
wouldn't be surprised if uh that could
be in the cards because you know UFC
knows what what good business is they
know it's all about attention big names
big fights especially when I finish kind
of the way I think I'm going to in a
dominant fashion
um it could very well be in the cards
and I would love to go out there and you
know fight Islam or whoever has the
title at that point would you stay at 70
would you consider staying at 70 if they
go we'll give you touch up it's at 70
because it's kind of a oh it's a it's
got to be jumbled up you know shoot I
mean maybe I mean I wouldn't be wouldn't
be opposed to it you know it depends on
depends on if I mean if it's a title
shot obviously but it'd have to be the
right match up at 170. you know Colby
Covington
thought we would be a good fight you
know I would love that he'll be fine I
loved I loved the idea of the miles but
I'll fight man I wish him well in
retirement I loved that fight
um you know Diaz I'm sure Diaz is gonna
end up coming back and he'll fight at
170 you know so like there's some cool
big fun fights out there too if I don't
if I don't get the title shot
um but like I said I don't think I
deserve a title shot necessarily but if
they give it to me I ain't saying no yup
hell no and we'll get you out of here on
this I know you're you're busy dude and
one thing I respect is when guys are
parlaying you know their opportunity you
know in the spotlight and doing other
businesses you got a lot going on you
got some golf event yesterday you got
you you you're doing all that you still
got your your fitness app and all that
stuff yeah and you got your podcast what
else we what are we doing here man what
else you got yeah so we're Yeah man so
we're building we're building a podcast
out the tough reaction show
um will be happening we have uh the
fastest growing peanut butter and jelly
sandwich company in the world cram
nutrition uh I gotta send you some of
those please do what's that about yeah
it's so it's essentially a healthy
adjustable so it's you know no crust but
it's all organic ingredients and uh no
sugar added high protein like 19 grams
of protein
destroy those too good I'll I'll send
you something just you know some some
Investments building the brand
continuing to get after it and uh you
know fitness app is doing well walk on
Fitness
um is doing well so we're enjoying it
we're enjoying the ride man I love it
man family's good kiddo's good they're
all good man growing like crazy getting
after it non-stop yeah it's getting
famous the the deal with it I guess I
can't figure it out well brother you
know yeah go ahead it all comes out good
it all comes out good I can't wait man
well I I can't wait for the fight to get
announced I'll be watching this season
I'll be hitting you up getting reactions
from you man you know that I'll be
checking in with you and uh you know I
think the world of you brother keep
crushing it man I'm so [__] proud of
you dude keep crushing me thank you bro
all right brother I appreciate you man
thank you for having me yes sir see you
boys